[Music]
good morning everybody while Kevin and I
are so excited to announce some of the
nominations for the 52nd Annual Academy
of Country Music Awards you know I love
my country all right well let's get
right to it with our first category new
male vocalist of the year presented by
t-mobile and the nominees are
Kayne Brown Chris Janssen Chris Lane
John party Bret young and four new
female vocalist of the year presented by
t-mobile the nominees are Lauren Alaina
cam brandy Klark Maren Morris next new
vocal duo or group of the year presented
by t-mobile the nominees are a thousand
horses brothers Osbourne dan + Shay
loCash Maddie in tank and the nominees
her songwriter of the year are ashley
Gourley Luke Laird Hilary Lindsey Shane
McAnally and Lori McKenna
all right next let's jump to Album of
the year the nominees are black by
Dierks Bentley dig your roots Florida
Georgia line hero Maren Morris ripcord
Keith Urban the weight of these wings
Miranda Lambert the nominees for single
record of the year are Balu ate your
color Keith Urban holy Florida Georgia
line humble and kind Tim McGraw my
church Marin Moore's and vice Miranda
Lambert all right for a cm song of the
year the nominees are gluing your color
Keith Urban died a happy man Thomas
Rhett humble and kind Tim McGraw kill a
word Eric Church featuring Rhiannon
Giddens Tennessee whiskey Chris
Stapleton vice Miranda Lambert and the
nominees for video of the year presented
by Xfinity
buy our way Chris Stapleton forever
country artist of then now and forever
humble and kind Tim McGraw Peter Pan
Kelsea Ballerini and vice Miranda
Lambert the nominees for vocal event of
the year are different for girls
Dierks Bentley featuring Elle King
forever country artists of then now and
forever may we all Florida Georgia line
featuring Tim McGraw setting the world
on fire Kenny Chesney featuring pink
think of you Chris
featuring cassadee Pope well the 52nd
annual ACM Awards will air live from Las
Vegas Sunday April the second on CBS you
don't want to miss it no it should be a
great show join us on ET and ET online
for all your ACM news
you